- Welcome back, everybody.
Happy Halloween!
(audience applauding)
I'm here with Keith
Morrison and Kyle Richards,
and our next guest is
a very, very funny man.
You've seen him on "Wild'N Out,"
and you can also see him now
as the host of "Celebrity
Squares," Tuesdays on VH1.
- It's your guy, DC Young Fly,
host of the new "Celebrity Squares."
Let's talk about these topics.
What's your favorite pose?
- Don't have me do a handstand
up here on this platform.
- Handstand, handstand, handstand.
(audience applauding)
Let's talk about these prizes.
Correct!
And can we talk about these celebrities?
Y'all make some noise
for Miss Tisha Campbell!
I'm done talking, let's play.
- I love a game.
(audience applauding)
Please welcome DC Young Fly, everybody.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
We are vampires.
- We are family.
- [Kelly] Is it hard to talk for you?
- Yes, I can't say nothing.
- I know.
I have to comment on, this is not...
It's your normal costume,
you look so sharp every episode,
man, I love how you dress.
(audience applauding)
- [DC Young Fly] Thank you.
- Yes.
I know.
(audience cheering)
I do, I love how you dress.
It's so sharp, I love it.
- I had to, you know what
I'm saying, step it up,
you know what I mean, put on a suit,
take the street the clothes off
and just (hisses) sharpen up a little bit.
- You said (hisses).
(Kelly laughs)
So wait, did you get into
costumes when you were a kid?
- I tried to do a little
something, something.
See, this a real vampire.
See, back in the day, I
couldn't be the real vampire.
Like, we had the teeth, but
I ain't never had the cape
or none of that stuff.
You know, we got our
teeth from Family Dollar.
- Oh.
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
- So these teeth right here,
this the longest the teeth
have ever stayed in my mouth.
(audience laughing)
- We did the Family Dollar as well.
People were like, "We're
going to Party City,"
I'm like, "You're rich."
(audience laughing)
- At Family Dollar, we had the ones
that go up top and the
ones that go on the bottom,
like you can see it when we talking.
- And it like came out
as you were talking.
- I spit on everybody.
- Connected, I know.
(audience laughing)
I know, I think I spit on Kyle earlier,
and I was like, oh my god.
(Kyle laughs)
So much saliva, I'm just saying.
- Do you see Keith?
- I know!
(DC Young Fly yells)
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Wait, so I imagine you
were like the class clown,
have you always been
like a little comedian?
- Man, I always had a good sense of humor,
you know what I mean,
just coming up from the
west side of Atlanta,
you dig what I'm saying?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But you know, I never thought
I was gonna be a comedian.
- [Kelly] No?
- I never thought, but you know,
when God directed my foot path,
you know what I mean, my steps,
I just kept on going, ya dig?
- Yeah, well, God will
give you an opportunity,
you have to take the
opportunity and run with it.
- Every opportunity and
put it in a choke hold.
- So since you weren't always into it,
have you ever had stage freight,
like been scared of the stage?
- You know, I come from
theater, so you know.
(audience cheering)
- All right, all right.
- We got some theater majors in here!
- [Kelly] Yes!
- Yes, sir!
So I come from theater,
so it wasn't ever hard for me to adjust,
I just never knew
that I always had to be a comedian first,
'cause I did music, so I never knew
that I had to tell jokes for a living.
- Yeah.
But wait, but I have to ask,
even with theater
though, I knew friends...
I wasn't ever like really stage freight,
but I had friends that were
terrified, even in theater.
- No, like this right here, I love this.
This right here?
You see this?
(audience applauding)
See, you gotta know how
to own that right there.
(Kelly laughs)
I'm pointing at you!
So that's part of theater,
see, people don't understand that
y'all are part of the emotion,
so when we on stage, when we hear y'all,
every time we do something
and we hear y'all,
to the actors that's on stage,
we like, hm, maybe we should get more deep
into what we doing,
because the audience is
letting us know, I feel ya.
- They're responding, yeah.
- Right.
- Yeah.
Have y'all ever been stage freight?
- Oh, yes.
- Sure, I got it right now.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- You're hiding it well.
- I went to hypnotherapy for-
- No!
- [Kelly] Did you said
you went to therapy?
- I went to hypnotherapy for it,
yes, I did.
- Oh!
Does that work?
'Cause I'd really like to not love sugar.
(audience laughing)
- I think it works.
I did it also for flying,
my fear of flying.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- But, yeah.
- I used to have
a huge fear of flying.
- You scared of flying?
You scared of flying now?
- I'm not anymore.
- Oh, okay.
- The hypnotherapy worked.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
You know what helped me a bit,
is I took lessons in flying.
I was terrified at first-
- I'm not that fearless. (laughs)
- So you got hypnotized?
- I did.
(audience laughing)
(DC Young Fly hisses)
(DC Young Fly and audience laughing)
- So like watch out,
if we like clap twice, she
might cluck like a chicken.
- Exactly, I'll just go.
- Yeah, it's like go out.
(audience laughing)
So wait, so hosting "Celebrity Squares,"
is this fun?
You look like you're having so much fun.
- Is it?
I want to bring all y'all onto the show.
Keith, you gonna come to the show?
- I'm coming, yeah.
- "Celebrity Squares,"
you gonna come, Kelly?
- I love games.
- You gonna come?
- I'm there.
- [DC Young Fly] See, this
what I'm talking about.
(audience applauding)
- Only if I can play against them.
- That's all it's about.
You know, it's just a
family oriented show,
you know what I'm saying?
It's a game where we play tic-tac-toe,
but we got so many people
that's on the cast,
like Chico Bean, you know what
I'm saying, Karlous Miller,
we even got Babyface.
- I love Babyface.
- Babyface, yeah.
- Babyface, Keith, you know Babyface?
- I love Babyface.
- Oh, Keith loves Babyface!
(audience laughing)
- Oh my god.
- But we done brought such
a great energy to VH1,
and I feel like "Celebrity
Squares" gonna be here
for 10 plus years.
- Yeah, people love to
tune in for like a fun game
and everybody kind of
out of their element,
seeing them do something
else, I love that.
- And not only that, you can be yourself.
'Cause you know, we all got jobs,
but also we wanna have fun too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So it's like, what show can we come on
that we can just chill and-
- You have fun?
- [Kelly] You have fun?
- [DC Young Fly] You
don't have on your show?
- We don't have fun, no.
- That's 'cause you're always
talking about death, man.
- Every night.
(audience laughing)
I just watched you last
night for three hours.
- Was I talking about death?
- Yes!
(audience laughing)
- I don't have fun on
my show either. (laughs)
- Wait, I have to ask though,
'cause I did not think
I would be a host ever.
Do you have any kind of learning curve,
like a thing that happened to you
that you were like, woo, okay?
- But see, in theater when you...
That's why I come from theater,
because it's like improv.
It's like a monkey wrench.
When somebody throws something out there,
you got to adjust fast.
- Yeah.
- So when I'm doing the hosting,
it's just more so me
being in my head saying,
how can I be the best host right now
if I was a host, who I am,
and why would I be hosting?
And I had to bring that energy.
I don't never limit myself.
You know, I always feel
like I could do anything,
especially God keep waking
me up every morning,
I'ma go to work.
(audience applauding)
- I love it, I love it.
All right, we need
another commercial break,
but you can catch DC Young
Fly host "Celebrity Squares"
Tuesdays on VH1.